لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت القصف في غزه اسرائيل
تواصل حربها على القطاع الجيش الاسرائيلي
وككل مره يجرب اسلحه وتقنيات جديده
استخدام ليس فقط من باب العقيده القتاليه
الباحثه عن الجديد بل من جانب المصالح
التجاريه لشركات الاسلحه الاسرائيليه
الحكوميه بحسب ما رصدته صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط
مصادر امنيه اسرائيليه كشفت عن استخدام
تقنيات حديثه خاصه في المسيرات ساعدت على
تنسيق العمليات بين الجيش والمخابرات ما
مكن من اغتيال عدد من القاده في ان واحد
خلال وقت قصير
ومن ابرز التجديدات استخدام منظومه مقلاع
داود التي تعد واحده من اربع منظومات
دفاعيه يعتمدها الجيش الاسرائيلي هي القبه
الحديديه
منظومه مقلاعدا طورت لتغطيه التهديدات
التي تقع بين نطاق اختصاص القبه الحديديه
ومنظومه السهم مثل تهديدات الصواريخ
متوسطه وطويله المدى بين 70 و 270
كيلومترا وكذا مجابهه التقنيات
التكنولوجيه المتطوره مثل صواريخ اسكندر
الروسيه مثلا ما يميز هذه المنظومه انها
تنقض على الهدف وتلتصق به مهما فعل من
مناورات للتهرب وتتمتع بقدرات عاليه
للتشويش على رادارات العدو ففي سنوات
سابقه كان الجيش الاسرائيلي يبادر الى
عمليه حربيه مره كل ثلاث الى اربع سنوات
واضعا لها عده اهداف منها ادخال الجنود في
تدريب عملي لحرب مباشره واجراء تجارب على
اداء الاسلحه او الذخيره الجديده الصنع
لكنه توقف عن هذه الوتيره السريعه
للعمليات فقط في ظل حكم بنيامنه اذ دخل في
صدام مباشر معه في عده قضايا واصبح يخشى
ان يتم تسخير الحرب لخدمه مصالحه الشخصيه
لكن يبدو ان نتنياهو حقق ما اراد فاستطلاع
للراي اجرته صحيفه معارف الاسرائيليه كشف
ان العمليه الاخيره ساعدت نتنياهو على
تعويض فارق النقاط مع وزير الدفاع السابق
بنجانتس وبذلك فان حزبيهما سيحصلان على 27
مقعدا في الكنيست اذا اجريت الانتخابات
الان بلال الوجداني العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات